what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we're gonna try something
different in this video it's like about
640 in the morning right now and I woke
up maybe half an hour ago and my voice
is deeper when I first wake up then
later on in the day and so I want you
guys to hear what my voice sounds like
relatively close it's actually deeper
than this when I first wake up but it'll
actually start to go back to normal as
we get through this video so I think
it's kind of a cool little experiment
that we're gonna do but anyway in this
video we are covering Superman rebirth
and again this is like the this is the
story call it last days and this is
really really cool
this story focuses on the destruction of
a planet similar to the events of
Krypton is really what this is about now
initially this picks up with Superman
and Jonathan Kent in the fortress of
solitude this is kind of cool because
Jonathan's been in the fortress before
but really for him being a kid each time
is like the first time like it really is
exciting and it's new and it's fresh
it's always really really interesting
there's a kind of bond that that
Superman and Jonathan's share outside of
the fact that they're father and son
they are basically the last survivors of
Krypton they really are in a lot of
different ways when you have Supergirl
Kara zor-el you know so and so forth yet
crypto but for Jonathan and Superman
they are basically the third their it
they're the last survivors there's a
kind of part of his legacy that he'll
never be able to fully grasp like you'll
never be able to walk on the grounds of
Krypton and that's what's so cool about
this is because what Superman is doing
is is basically sitting down and giving
Jonathan this bit of its history and in
essentially a holographic recording of
Krypton's destruction the problem with
this is that almost immediately after
the whole thing begins when he sees the
other the whole situation over the
course of an hour it is pretty grave in
terms of how it impacts him but almost
immediately after this whole thing ends
they're suddenly met by an alert system
and this is actually pretty cool what
Superman had done is he had basically
set up an alert system or program do the
fortress to basically alert him in the
instance that there was a planet
anywhere in the universe that was going
to face the same end as Krypton what
this does is it allows the Man of Steel
to basically do what his father couldn't
to show up to another world that's going
to be destroyed in the same capacity as
Krypton and save it it seems like it's a
little more personal of a superhero epic
than anything else now of course the
funny thing is that Jonathan wants to go
right Jonathan yes let me go you have to
let me tell you have to let me go and of
course two bands initial responses no
you can't it's really dangerous out
there you know spaces spaces a dangerous
place but ultimately Jonathan
Venson so Superman's response is like
okay look you can go but like don't tell
your mom which of course that makes
perfect sense
I mean if Jonathan goes running home
right there's what I love Jonathan kids
character if Jonathan you know Jonathan
goes running home mom you won't believe
what happened dad took me into space and
we went to like a planet that was like
two or three solar systems away Lois
Lane's response would be like honey you
need to go upstairs
dad and I need to have a conversation
man she'd rake him over the coals like
do and there'll be nobody to help but
when they get there what they end up
finding out is of course this planet is
called a called galley man but it's
interesting once they get there Superman
kind of runs over the ecology of events
to expect whenever they arrive on a new
planet you know of course it says look
the Green Lantern's have been haven't
been to more planets and I have it
actually a trailer Drake has a really
really good uh yeah I guess comic Drake
has a really really good video on where
the Green Lantern of Krypton was like
why the Green Lantern of Krypton wasn't
there when Krypton blew up which is
actually kind of a cool question I never
thought about answering before but like
he basically says it look like what's
gonna happen is we're gonna show up
they're gonna be dazzled by our powers
ultimately people are gonna be a little
fascinated what passes for the security
forces are gonna take us to their local
leaders and then we're basically gonna
plead our case to say hey we're here to
essentially save your world because
obviously you probably don't know that
it's gonna be destroyed the exact
opposite happens Superman gets there
alongside Jonathan Kent and what's been
going on here is basically like a
religious fanaticism that like the the
leaders of the planet are like yeah we
know the planets gonna blow up and like
it's the will of our God to make it
happen so leave now depending on how you
view the world you'll look at this story
in one of two ways people who are
against any kind of fanaticism will look
at this and say those guys are crazy
those guys are absolutely nuts whereas
somebody else might look at that and say
but that's what they believe like who
were you to be so arrogant in your moral
righteousness to show up and say hey
other people from a world that I've
never seen before I know better than you
do and so you need to do what I want you
to do because I know better than you do
and it's cool because it's two different
conflicting ideas both of which have
validity that are basically clashing
with one another Superman showing up
here is look your world's going to be
destroyed and you're all gonna die
but their perspective here is yeah we
know that and it's the will of our God
so let it happen and it's just like okay
well who's right here now the initial
response is Superman's initial response
is surely you don't speak on behalf of
the entirety of your citizenry the
response is like our our God wants this
to happen and
if you don't leave we're going to kill
you of course Superman's response is
like okay look unless you've got like
kryptonite magic or like a red Sun in
your pocket somewhere that I can't see
then like you're not gonna be able to
take me down and basically that's
exactly what they've been doing they
practice a kind of faith magic is it's
kind of an ambiguous term to basically
say they have abilities and aren't fully
fleshed out but basically they just
start sapping away the energy of
Superman and John the kid and the result
is that they basically does kind of have
to flee for their life now ultimately
they come across a guy who's basically
like the last scientist on the planet
and that's when we start to learn a
little bit of the history of this world
they're by some means or another faith
or I guess so belief in religion
ultimately began to win out and that's
the missing link here we don't really
know exactly how it happened all we know
is that there was basically a point
where religion went out scientists
became the minority and then there was a
great purge and they basically executed
all the scientists on the on the planet
and the result is that all you had left
was faith and so this guy is like the
last remaining scientists on the world
and so because of this the goal is to
basically find a way to save their
planet to keep it protected but notice
this and it's kind of cool notice this
you know when he takes them back to
their back to his lab he basically has
the exact same situation as Krypton now
sure
Krypton wasn't necessarily it was really
more like ignorance or it was really
more like this is preposterous there's
no way our worlds weren't and it was
really more like arrogance as opposed to
like a faith based system but the whole
idea here is that they look at this the
scientist is kind of like look the world
is going to end and they believe that
it's the will of God Dermott or whatever
their gods name is and so there's really
nothing we can do to stop that
I mean they're you can't you can't beat
you know reason into them and you can't
even beat them to change their minds if
you do they're doing what you tell them
to not because they actually believe it
and if you can't didn't the only thing
you can do is just get while the
getting's good the world's burning down
around you right I mean this is a
classic example you wake up one morning
and the paint's peeling and the curtains
are gone
you know and the water's boiling what do
you do it's like well you get out
because your house is on fire and that's
exactly what happens here he kind of
looks around and says this entire
society is now a lost cause
they're beyond the hope of reason
they've descended into madness at least
as far as he's concerned from a
scientific perspective they're willing
to doom all their lives because they
believe it's the will of their God and
so now like all we can do is just escape
and so much like the story of jor-el
what this guy's done is constructed a
kind of stasis for the various eggs of
him and his wife and of course he built
a rocket that
allow them to escape but the problem is
that once these folks come barreling in
once all these different soldiers and
community of so on and so forth comes
smashing in of course the rock gets
destroyed and this guy is basically
injured in the process meaning that
Superman and Jonathan are really the
only ones left now the result is that I
guess because their powers sort of waxed
and waned based on their faith that
Superman's powers begins to you know
begin to basically start to come back
and he sends Jonathan out and he's like
grab the eggs take off go to an asteroid
keep those things safe because those are
the lasts in this race now of course
this also sees this scientist basically
dying out and that's really about it but
Superman tries one last time because the
tremors start to roll through and so
because of this Superman tries to reason
one last time right it's like it was
like look guys I get that you guys have
faith I get that you guys believe in a
Power greater than yourself
but you guys also have to recognize that
if this power greater than yourself gave
you life then it would want to believe
that you will live like it wants you to
live and if that's the case why would
you sacrifice your life but that's kind
of the cool thing is the response is you
don't know that there's no way you could
know that like this is our faith this is
our belief system let us have our belief
and again it's so cool because like you
could look at Superman and say he's
genuinely trying to save these people
but then on the other hand say but why
would someone so arrogant show up to
somebody else's home and say I know
better than you do like sure you believe
in in a god but like you don't really
know the way the universe works but I
know the way the universe works so you
need to follow me because I am going to
save you from yourselves it seems so
exceedingly arrogant to show up and to
say that but it's not out of place of
there's nothing a place of malice right
it sound like Superman's a guy who
travels around the cosmos and it's like
everyone listen to me everyone noticed
me because of how powerful I am and
because of how experienced I am and wise
I am and you should all do what I want
you to do because I'm just that great
this is coming from a place of genuinely
trying to do good of genuinely trying to
save these people and valuing the
sanctity of life and that's where I say
ultimately Superman wins out here is
even if you have a battle between these
guys who believe their God wants him to
die versus Superman who's trying to save
them ultimately a really a suit man
who's just a good guy here he's trying
to save a race of people who have not
yet come to the realization that just
because they believe in a being doesn't
mean that beings should necessarily
encompass every single aspect of their
life in its totality and so with this in
mind like ultimately Superman is kind of
forced to leave
they don't want to leave they don't want
to you know survive the destruction of
this planet they believe that it's
genuinely the will of their God and so
the result is that super mayor just kind
of has to leave with a heavy heart as
the entire plan is destroyed and
ultimately you know all that's really
left are these eggs but it's crushing
it's kind of a crushing thing right I
mean what this means and really the
lesson Jonathan's learning here is you
can't save everybody especially those
who don't want to save themselves it's
kind of a crazy situation because for
the most part from from Jonathan Kent's
perspective with the exception of like a
few isolated incidents here and there
from Jonathan Kent's perspective he
still has the idea that every single
time that he and his father fly into
some conflict on some planet somewhere
if that ever happens and there's some
race it's stuck in turmoil that they'll
celebrate the arrival of Superman and
Jonathan that they'll welcome them in
that they'll say please please save us
and Jonathan and Superman will save them
and the day will be saved and I'll be
like a parade and all these great things
are happened because by golly they're
superheroes and they're just doing the
right thing that's the image that he
built up in his head in a lot of ways
but then suddenly they come across a
race of people who don't want to save
themselves but it's interesting because
Jonathan asks him this really cool
question he asked him do you believe in
God and this was so interesting about
Superman is there are people who would
look to Superman and see him as a god
but Superman's response is not
necessarily yes I believe in God his
response is I believe in something there
has to be something out there like
there's too much organization too much
structure too much reason in this
universe to believe that it's all just
arbitrary but maybe it is and maybe
there was just a prime mover maybe
there's just a person that set things in
motion and then now we've ended up where
we currently are now of course
unbeknownst to Superman yes Superman God
does exist and he's blue walks around
naked and he's got the little atom
symbol on his head and he's absolutely
gonna stomp the hell out of you and
everybody else in the Justice League if
you choose to fight him yeah Superman
he's there you just haven't seen him yet
but God is real and you are going to
meet him Homeslice
then you go find out how real God is but
it is a cool story it is a really really
cool story it's basically a it's a
coming-of-age tale for Jonathan more so
than anything else
it's Jonathan learning the lesson that
you can't save everyone that sometimes
no matter how hard you try you can't
save everybody all you can do is save as
many people as you can
assuming that you can save any at all
it's a hard lesson to learn but it's a
very important lesson to learn
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]